[Applaudissements]
kikou les boys and girls déjà le
quatrième toute hausse de la dore modem
si quelque chose me dit que vous allez
devenir des vrais petits dancing machine
et peut-être qu'ils s'aiment avoir un
corps comme ça regardez ça fait rêver
je comprends aller j'ai dit les boys
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce que
tu fais là toi non je suis pas un boss
mais je fais là de leurs modèles vont
traîne depuis des mois cette playmate
qu'est ce que j'en ai à [ __ ] que tu
veux faire c'est pas l'armée du salut tu
es gentil près ce que c'est qu'un boys
camille hockey les filles quand vous
serez faire ça vous serez les boys en
attendant europe du ballet où ce merci
beaucoup
sorry pour cette perte de temps ça
m'énerve de leur modèle et on commence
deux garçons avec leur tournée agacé au
alors on regarde loin devant on est sexy
on avance un petit peu et là nouveau pas
c'est le cléopâtre du lobe au attention
quand ils profitent games as a way
profil profil comme facebook et encore
profil bravo didon c'est bien j'aime ce
que je vois je vois ce que j'aime après
attention très souvent le flamant rose
sept tours aux commandes des flamants
roses et bien il est sur une jambe
il sera pas un peu fatigué d'être
toujours sur une jambe ce flamand
changement jobs changement d'homme avec
les m16 et dansant et dorment pour bravo
mille euros se plaint monrose
mais ce qu'ils n'avaient pas vu en
cherchant l'amour c'est qu'un vilain
chasseur était dans le coin et pan il
tombe
himeur y meurt mais il danse il est
toujours en vol bien sûr bravo les boys
après deux ans moderne c'est maintenant
je vois tout le monde debout et toute la
france dans ces yeah bonjour est basé
loti un petit nouveau comme ils
s'appellent salut je t'échange action
boys et ben walker jacques et welcome
chez vous vous êtes prêt d'honneur
modèle 1 2 3 musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
y est nouveau et bravo à bout chez vous
et qui sait peut-être un cinquième tut
hausse de la doller moderne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]